welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is professor Eric harms an assistant
professor in the department of
anthropology professor harms is a socio
cultural anthropologist with research
interests in the study of urban and
peri-urban life and rural urban
transitions he specializes in the
political economic and social
transformations engulfing the
post-colonial mega cities of Southeast
Asia and has carried out extensive
fieldwork in and around ho chi minh city
in Vietnam today we'll talk with
Professor harms about his newest book
Saigon zedge welcome professor harms
well hi hi Marilyn thank you for
inviting me I'm looking forward to our
conversation great let's talk a little
bit about your book what is the premise
of Saigon zedge well Saigon zedge is my
first book and as a young anthropologist
I decided that one of the most important
things I need to do in this book is
really express my commitment to
ethnographic description so the book
actually has three projects in it the
most important being the first is really
just a simple straightforward
ethnographic description of life on
Saigon zedge which is the shorthand I
use to describe the rural-urban
transition zone on the outskirts of Ho
Chi Minh City the second the second
project that I have in the book is
really to explore what I would I
conceived of as the intersection or the
interplay between ideological
conceptions and configurations of the
rural and the urban as ideal categories
and the everyday realities and everyday
practices of people who live in these in
this city so that second project is
really about trying to show the way in
which people negotiate systems of ideals
with the everyday of ways and a
of living and the exigencies of being a
human being living in the world and the
third project is as all theoretical
works must be in some sense is a
engagement with the contemporary urban
studies theory and I try to use the case
of Ho Chi Minh City and the ways in
which these people negotiate the their
lives on the urban margin as a
contribution to some of the recent work
that's been carried out in other cities
around the world and to try to discover
what's particular Vietnamese about this
case so let me talk a little bit about
some of those three different areas of
interest in terms of ethnographic
description what I really want to convey
is what it's like to live on a city
that's on the edge and when I when I use
this term the edge it occurred to me in
the middle of my fieldwork that Vietnam
itself is a country on the edge it's on
the it's it's often portrayed as the
next frontier in emerging the capitalist
markets it's on the edge of socialism
the edge of capitalism it's a as the
Vietnamese government describes it it's
a it's a market economy with the
socialist orientation and so what I'm
really trying to get to is use the study
of everyday life in the city to describe
what it means to live on the edge of an
economic transformation in that sense so
that's that's one angle in which I
described the contours of social life
but to get to that you really need to
get into people's lives and so I looked
to the edge of the city as a way to
describe in some sense in a microcosm
the experience of living on the edge
both as a nation as a whole and the
spatial edge of the city and I see it as
a very interesting place for example let
me give you a few examples you have
rapid transformation of urban land use
so what was formerly rice producing
fields or vegetable farms will nowadays
be the site of the actual insertion of
capital in the four
of new factories Korean Taiwanese own
shoe factories places that are making
industrial webbing for export and the
the real insertion of export processing
zones that one sees in this rapidly
expanding economy really takes place on
the edge of the city itself and so one
of the things I try to do is really just
tell stories listen to people as they as
they tell me about their lives the first
thing i did when i arrived in to my
field site which is in hoc mon district
in the rural urban margin of Saigon was
basically walk along the highway i would
spend hours every day walking along the
side of the highway where there were
houses that were being demolished the
front of the house was being torn off
literally the the front living room of
houses would be removed so that they
could expand this highway and widen the
width of the road and basically this is
the story that people would tell we they
would say we are sacrificing the front
of our homes in order to allow for
Vietnamese for the Vietnamese nation to
develop so this this notion of being on
the edge ultimately emerged out of the
stories that people would tell me in the
way in which someone who used to run a
little cafe in the front of their house
all of a sudden would lose that cafe and
sacrifice a business opportunity but
reserve their their antagonism for
losing this property and oftentimes
submit their their their potential
animosity or anger or displeasure and re
articulate that in terms of a notion of
sacrificing one sells for the total
development of the country another other
things that you would see is a people
trying to carve out niches in which they
could make make ends meet so for example
one of the most enduring images I have
in my mind is of cemeteries on
outskirts of the city which all of the
land between the the tombstones was
basically converted into agricultural
land so you have quite literally
vegetables growing from the soil of
one's ancestors and people would talk
about these these this relationship of
Viet Nam's past and how sacrificing the
past in some sense was necessary in
order to feed the possibility of the
future and so this image the stories
that people would tell about the
strategies that they had in order to
make ends meet these are the kinds of
things that I set out to really document
in detail in in telling the story of
Saigon zedge sometimes the stories would
be stories of triumph for example there
was a Vietnamese pig farmer who came
from the United States he received he
received workers compensation payments
for a small accident that he had while
working in a factory in in Massachusetts
then he moved to Saigon zedge which he
saw as this zone of possibility where he
could basically convert the money he was
getting from workers compensation
payments into investment opportunity and
so then he built this gigantic pig pig
processing factory and lots of he hired
a lot of laborers to take care of these
pigs and in a sense he saw the edge of
the city as this space of potential
where he could transform small bits of
money that he had earned in the United
States into a massive fortune in Vietnam
on the other hand I had other friends
who would tell me about the ways in
which living on the edge of the city
basically was a form of social
marginalization a sense that they had no
say and the politics of City Planning
and the development of the city as it
grew out over the lands in which they
had lived for many generations and they
told me about how the fact that they
lived on the outside of the city itself
was a form of alienation and
displacement where they had no voice so
one of the things that I tried
do in the book is to combine these kind
of stories of triumphant and stories of
despair and alienation and carve out an
understanding of built from the stories
that people themselves tell about what
it's like to live on the edge of a
rapidly expanding city so did the book
grow out of the stories that that people
had told you I mean how did you come to
write the book was it through the
stories or did you have an idea prior
well there's always a little bit of a
give and take in you know I was
interested in Vietnam and I was
interested in notions of the rapid
economic transformation that's taking
place there and thinking of a way to
have an ethnographic approach to
understanding that and I was interested
in some of the simplifications that come
when one talks about rural Vietnam and
urban Vietnam as these strictly opposed
dichotomies and so looking into the edge
I saw it as a place where all the
simplifications are blurred in some
sense so that brought me to the edge of
the city and so a place as I said I
wanted to study a place that had one
foot in the country and one foot in the
city as a place to really look at
urbanization in process also a place
that I could go back to overtime and
well today it's in this in the
countryside five years from now it will
be partially in the city in ten years
it'll probably be another suburb of the
city itself so that got me interested in
this particular site but as an
anthropologist one of the things that
really made it difficult for me to come
in with preconceived conceptions is I
expected everyone to be angry you know
to feel cheated or like as victims of
some kind of large-scale process of
capitalization or you know the
transformation of their livelihoods and
things but I found that in fact people
weren't angry they had a much more
complex reaction to the transformations
taking place so that's where the stories
had to inform the way I understood what
I was seeing and the stories actually
the stories themselves are often quite
banal are quite simple there's nothing
dramatic there's no story
of you know a very strange phenomenon
there's no ghost stories there's no
outrageous forms of exploitation or
corruption there are stories of minor
grievances minor issues or minor
complications they add up to a sense of
negotiation and navigation of life on
the outer city districts now as I
started to hear people talk one thing
did emerge though is that and this is
the next premise of the book in some
sense of trying to understand the idea
of symbols and how a city takes on a
symbolic meaning one of the things I was
really interested in is how even though
the city is growing rapidly and the
places that were formerly agricultural
are really just newer 'ben sectors of
the center city are still conceived of
in strict terms that differentiate the
rural from the urban now in in urban
studies Theory people talk about
Southeast Asian cities and there's all
kinds of geographers and anthropologists
who have invented new terms to describe
these kind of places famous term is
called dad s acota which is an
indonesian term that combines the words
for country and city it's a kind of
country cities own right and this is
what you see here on the outskirts of Ho
Chi Minh City but the people who live
there they never refer to some kind of
anomalous space they refer to either the
inside of the city or the outside of the
city the urban zone or the rural zone
and so I was very fascinated by the way
in which despite what we might call
empirical or objective transformations
of the landscape nevertheless people
would hold on to very discrete
categories that ordered things into what
in the social scientists we would think
as a kind of old-fashioned binary
opposition's which is reminiscent of
early structuralism or something that
often social scientists are now quite
skeptical of the simple categories of
opposition nevertheless as an
anthropologist you can be skeptical of
categories but you also have to listen
to the stories people say
and the ways in which people articulate
what they would the way they see the
world and so for me it was quite
fascinating to say what is why are
people thinking in terms of inside and
outside when these differences are
obviously so blurred in everyday life so
I started a thing how do what is a model
for this and this ultimately became the
theoretical intervention of the book in
some sense where I recognize that the
model for inside and outside that one
sees laid out on the spatial
organization of Ho Chi Minh City is
actually analogous and very parallel and
very similar to the model of kinship
organization that you see in the way in
which Vietnamese families are organized
so let me give you an example in
Vietnamese kinship there's a there's a
patrilineal ideal which is the which is
based on the inner lineage so if you're
a member of a patra line you're inside
the lineage and in Vietnamese it's been
annoyed no it means inside so if you're
the father's father the paternal
grandfather you'll be Illinois which
means you're like the inside grandpa if
you're the mother's father in a family
you would be my which means the outside
grandpa so in the spatial conception of
a kinship relationship in the ideal form
you have this notion that there's an
inside and an outside now what's
actually quite fascinating about how
that that kind of kinship system works
is that when a wife Mary's into the
family there's an implicit contradiction
that takes place the wife comes from her
own patra line in some set marries into
the patcher line of her husband and she
is the outsider who enters into the city
now the wife in traditional Vietnamese
folklore mythology and like discussions
of the role of the wife the wife is both
highly denigrated and also idealized as
this pure other who is important to the
reproduction of the lineage so what's
very fascinating
gets complicated but so you have a very
simple contradiction actually the wife
comes from the outside and her job is to
reproduce the inside but the inside both
denigrates and val arises the wife now
if we look at the city the way people
conceptualize the city it's exactly the
same the outer city districts are both
simultaneously seen as the wasteland of
the city the place where you put
polluting factories and all these kind
of dangerous elements of the outside are
often symbolically associated with the
outside of the city but it's also the
place where agriculture and all of the
fresh food stuffs of the city come in
it's also sometimes called dalla for
which means the lungs of the city so in
the idealized symbolic understanding of
the relationship of the inside of the
city and the outside of the city it's
actually structurally very similar to
the relationships in kinship so this was
interesting to me I didn't know what to
do with it but ultimately what I
realized was if we look at kinship and
the way in which people navigate kinship
relations we see that people are
constantly transgressing ideals for
example there's this contradiction the
role of the wife to reproduce she's
supposedly denigrated all these things
she's also ID like but in real life in
real everyday practice people's families
are much more complex and there's
actually an oscillation between this
patrilineal ideal model and a bilateral
model of kinship that really valorize
'as the wife's side of the family as
well and actually opens up kinship
relations to a wide swath of all
potential family relations so there's a
notion of the inside as the ideal but
there's also a simultaneous valorisation
of the outside but they're posed when
you when you look at them in ideal terms
they're posed as opposition's they seem
like a contradiction but in fact in all
studies of Vietnamese kinship people
realize that most Vietnamese social
actors in reality oscillate between
these two forms what it does that
oscillation allows one to capitalize on
both the advantages of a kind of strong
rooted patra line that's ground
space like for example a patra line also
has it has land and property he located
in space you have a kind of permanent
home address right but when you're
outside relations are often spatially
mobile not fixed in place and hard to
and they have very little history
attached to them but they spread out
across territory you could find members
of the outside in California or in
France and it well dispersed across
territory in creating very strict
dichotomies of inside and outside people
are able to create spaces of potential
movement that actually allows them to
generate power both symbolic and also
very real material capital through this
oscillation between space so for example
the pig farmer who I mentioned the guy
who got money from his workers
compensation payments in the United
States took that money invested it in
the outer city districts of Ho Chi Minh
City he's actually able to enact a form
of oscillation where takes advantage of
the outer city districts as a site of
cheap land but he's able to create a
notion of his own self and his own
lineage which is rooted in a more
discreet bounded entity so he's able to
oscillate between generating capital in
one place outside of Vietnam but also to
insert that capital into the rural urban
margins and actually generate a certain
productivity out of that relationship so
how does Zygons edge fit into the other
work you've done in Vietnam well one of
the things that I've been trying to do
and all my work in Vietnam is one is to
understand there's these large
structural processes right you have
globalization urban transformations you
have you know rapid expansion of cities
that's taking place all over the world
right so one of the things I'm trying to
do here is to really find what's
Vietnamese about this so that's one of
the reason why I'm trying to explain
some of these possibilities through a
Vietnamese kinship model I could just
say it's well it's just
parodies of capital right to expand
outward and occupy more and more
territory and you know some people call
it the obliteration of space through
time it takes place and rampant global
capitalism that's one element but
there's also it's different than
cochabamba bolivia it's different than
lagos it's different than other cities
where these processes are taking place
so that's one thing the other thing I'm
really interested in is that the link
between symbolic meaning of space the
way in which space takes on certain
sensibilities and meanings and the
material ramifications of that so for
example if we if we look at the the
symbolic relation of inside and outside
in Vietnamese cities we can study that
as a kind of symbolism you know that's
linked to certain ideas or cosmologies
and things like that yin and yang
metaphors and things of that they are
quite prevalent in Vietnamese thinking
but we can also look at the very
particular effects of those symbolic
reckonings that transform like quite
literally like the value of real estate
the ability of people to generate
capital the people the way in which
people can port their bodies to
represent themselves as peasants when
they walk into the city in order to sell
goods that has a kind of symbolic value
but it also generates economic capital
as well so that's one thing another
issue that I'm very interested in and
this is the direction of my future work
is to take some of the ideas about the
symbolic meaning of space on the outer
city districts and apply it to the inner
city district so I've moved in so to
speak in my research has gone from the
outside in because a lot of the symbolic
meaning that I discovered on the outer
city district and that was really
affecting people's lives well that's
generated by discourses and ideas of the
city that often emerged from the centers
of power and from emerging middle class
in downtown Ho Chi Minh City and so my
new project is to create what I call a
the map of the spatial divisions of
labor in Ho Chi Minh City to really
create an ethnographic map that emerges
from interviews and stories and working
with
colleagues at the University of social
sciences and humanities in Ho Chi Minh
City to create a map of the way in which
different districts in the city are
attributed certain symbolic meanings and
how that relates to the actual
productive activity that takes place
like a working-class district all of a
sudden becomes a place where there's a
lot of motor bike repair shops or a
fancy district has lots of high-end
cafes and discos and think but like to
really systematize what at this point
are sort of relatively anecdotal
observations about the city but
systematize it and understand how these
places are intermixed and interlocked
with each other in a kind of large-scale
division of labor other things with
studying civilizational discourse the
way in which people there's a rhetoric
of civilization was called ven minh in
vietnamese which is often used to
legitimize the displacement of large
sections of the population from certain
parts of the city and oftentimes what I
argue is that basically the discourse of
n men of civilization is the kind of a
veiled system of privatization basically
well all very interesting thank you very
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work well thank you
very much I've enjoyed talking about
this great for more information about
professor harms and his work including
his book saigon zedge please visit our
website at yale edu backslash macmillan
report please be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you